[Music]
game of thrones prequel series house of
the dragon although based on george rr
martin's targaryen history book fire and
blood will not feature only targaryens
but many other houses and many other
legendary figures from that time period
as well
from lord larry strong who is pretty
much a combination of varys in
littlefinger to alice rivers who has the
same abilities as melisandre
and likely is melisandre in her younger
days to nettles a dragon seed
who was either daemon's secret child or
his lover or even both
we also have craig and stark rhodey the
ruin and his legendary winter rules
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
prequel show that is confirmed by hbo's
president to air in 2022
miguel sapochnick and ryan condell will
serve as show runners and
executive producers george r martin will
also serve as executive producer
it's based on georgia martin's book fire
and blood vol 1
and on mars yet unfinished fire and
blood vol 2 book
fire and blood is about long and rich
history of house targaryen
the key event of the show is also the
key in the history of house targaryen
the dance of the dragons
the targaryen civil war which divided
the entire kingdom
and launched a huge war that was fought
from 129 ac to 131ac
the dance of the dragons was the most
devastating war in the history of the
seven kingdoms
the war of succession between aegon ii
and his half-sister rhaenyra over their
father viserys the first throne
both of them thought they belonged on
the iron throne when people started
declaring for one of them or the other
their fight divided the kingdoms in two
targaryens fought targaryens brothers
fought brothers
dragons fought the dragons by the time
it was over thousands were dead
not targaryens but nordman craig and
stark rotted the ruin
and his winter wolves play a big role in
the dance of the dragons
with kragen even becoming the main
character at one point
but for the most part he is a legendary
side character
craig and stark known as the old man of
the north the wolf of the north and the
wolf of wenefeld was the lord of inner
fell
and the head of house stark during the
targaryen civil war
before fighting someone else's war
cragan had to fight his own war to get
what was rightfully his
to take the rule of the north from his
uncle upon himself
three years before the dance of the
dragon started in 126 ac
kragen finally rose up against his uncle
and imprisoned banner than his three
sons
taking the rule of the north into his
own hands upon the death of king viserys
the first targaryen
rhaenyra's son prince jacary's valerian
flew to winterfell on his dragon vermax
to gain the support of the starks and
the north for his mother rhaenyra
targaryen's claim to the iron throne
the alliance known as the pact of ice
and fire stated that a targaryen
princess the future first born daughter
of jacarys would marry his son rickon
kragen pledged his support to the blacks
during the dance of the dragons
after prince jacary's valerian secured
the allegiance of the north for his
mother rhaenyra targaryen
lord craig and stark sent two thousand
soldiers known as the winter wolf south
commanded by his bannerman lord rodrick
dustin known as roddy de roy to support
the queen's claim
while he remained in the north to gather
his own banners
due to the vastness of the north this
would take long
by the start of the dance of the dragons
rogic was an old and hoary warrior
despite his advanced age he was still
considered a savage combatant on the
battlefield
roddy the ruined wore a shield the helm
and warhorn in battle
the winter wolves were grizzled soldiers
who rode shaggy northern horses
bore old male and ragged skins wielded
access smalls
spike maces and ancient iron swords we
have come to die for the dragon queen
said lord roderick while leading 2
thousand winter wolves into battle
there's probably nothing scarier than
fighting men who have come to die
during the battle by the lakeshore the
winter wolves led the attack
and charged the lannister spearmen 5
times with two-thirds of the northmen
killed or wounded
in their decisive victory for the blacks
during the butcher's bowl
lord rodriguez sounded the charge of the
winter wolves and the river knight
allies against sir kristen cole's army
in the ensuing butcher's bowl
a slaughter of the greens during the
first battle of tumbleton
the surviving winter wolves screamed
northern war cries
and rode from a postern gate despite
being outnumbered
by 10 to 1 lord rodrick led the northmen
in a charge against lord ormund
hightower
as the singers tell it lord rodrick was
blood from head to heel as he came
on yet so drunk with the battle that he
did not even seem to feel his wounds
lord dorman's nephew sir brynden was
able to cut off rodrik's shield arm with
a long axe
but the northern lord was able to kill
both hightowers before succumbing to his
wounds
rhaenyra fled king's landing after the
storming of the dragonpit while she was
staying at duskendale lord stark wrote
that he would gather for her a host of
ten thousand northmen younger and
fiercer than the fallen winter wolves
rainer was killed at dragonstone by king
aegon the second targaryen however
but kragen with his army still marched
south nonetheless in support of her son
prince aegon the younger he moved his
forces to claim king's landing where he
found that hagon ii
had been poisoned and dagon iii was now
a king
this event came to be known as the hour
of the wolf or the judgement of the wolf
speaking about betrayers lyrics strong
will also be an epic side character in
the upcoming prequel series
larry strong is a combination of heirs a
littlefinger being the one in shadows
orchestrating many events and dead so
powerful people
making kings rise and fall larry strong
known as larry's clubfoot or the
clubfoot
was the lord of harehole and head of
house strong
he served on the small council as the
master of whispers
and lord confess her for both kings
larrys rarely spoke
preferring to listen his older brother
harvin strong
is rumored to have fathered three of
rainer's children
historians are still baffled as to
exactly what clubfoot's loyalties and
goals were during the dance of the
dragons
as he sided with aegon but at the end
orchestrated his death
aside from possibly having his father
and brother killed to become lord of
house strong
everything he does during the targaryen
civil war is the mix of duty to the
realm
and self-preservation like varys he
stays loyal to his designated monarch
until that monarch threatens to bring
the realm down with him
like littlefinger he orchestrates that
monarch's death
was he becomes too much of a problem
switches sides and decides to create his
own rule by
reigning through an underage ruler
fortunes turned against lord strong
and his plotters with the arrival of the
northern army of lord craig and stark
who served as hand of the king to the
new king aegon iii
targaryen during the hour of the wolf
despite having been a supporter of
rhaenyra
craigan objected to the murder of again
the second
grand maester orwell confessed to having
given larry's the poison used to kill
aekon
and sir perkins confessed to being the
clubfoot's agent
but lord corliss admitted to having
conspired against aegon for the good of
the seven kingdoms
larysse refused to confirm or deny
creagan's accusations
lord stark condemned both of the great
lords but alisain black would convince
him to spare lord valerian
while most of those found guilty took
the black and joined the night's watch
lord larry's chose death over the wall
craigan beheaded him with his valyrian
steel greats or dice
next we have nettles who is believed to
be either demon's secret child or lover
nettles also known as nettie was the
dragon seed
and the first and possibly last dragon
rider of the dragon sheepstealer
natals was able to tame the wild dragon
sheepstealer
by bringing it a freshly slaughtered
sheep each morning
according to mushroom daemon had come to
love the girl and took her as his
bedmate
in contrast the maestro had made him
pull where the two stayed
stated the dragon riders had separate
bedrooms and the daemon doted up on
nettles as a man might dote upon his
daughter
when mr norren informed daemon that
rhaenyra had declared nettles a traitor
believing all dragon seeds are traitors
and believing nettles poisoned daemon's
mind
daemon disobeyed his queen and his
wife's order and allowed nettles to
escape
in her exile she went to the vale of
arena last but not the least we have
alice rivers
whose origins are shrouded in mystery
with some believing she is melisandre
herself
in her younger days alice looked
unusually young for her age
as she had to be at least 40 by the
outbreak of the dance of the dragons
and some even believe she was much older
than that alice reversed was a bad mate
of prince aemond
targaryen like melisandre she saw
visions in fire
that's how aemond learned that daemon
was waiting for him
in harrenhal when prince eamon flew back
to harehole to do battle with prince
daemon and characters
he took the pregnant alice with him
aymond told daemon that it was alice who
told him where to find him
as she saw vision in fire after daemon
killed the aemond
alice became the witch queen ruling
harrenhal
the hand of the king at the time sir
thailand lannister tasked ser regis
groves of the kingsguard and sir damon
dary
with reclaiming the castle and gave them
100 men
instead of yielding alice presented them
a young boy as eamon's true born son
and the rightful king instead of aegon
iii targaryen
regis abruptly died after insulting
ellis
eyewitnesses claimed she used magic to
burst his skull
alice's rebel then wrote from henderhole
and overwhelmed the loyalist men
with daemon fleeing with the remaining
men alice santa captured loyalists as a
messenger the following day
the survivor claimed that he had been
cursed by alice so that he would die if
anyone laughed at his story
he said ellis had instructed him that
any man who approached harrenhal
without submitting to its occupants
would die the man also insisted that he
had seen a dragon inside
despite daemon's assurance that no one
would laugh at the messenger story
one onlooker did so the messenger then
choked to death in moments
with some saying they had seen the
imprints of a woman's fingers on his
throat
her story will continue when george r
martin finishes fire and blood vol 2.
legendary side characters such as craig
stark roddy the roy nettles
larry sinellis legendary battles such as
the winter wolves charge into the
green's army
despite being outnumbered by 10 to 1 and
managing to reach the commander of the
greens
and seeing a stark rule the capital
king's landing all of that and more this
game of thrones prequel show house of
the dragon brings in 2022
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this video please give it a big
thumbs up and i hope to see you in the
next one
peace